philosophy visit the scenario where
everyone is trying to exit country B's
currency and convert it back into
country a we saw in the last video that
if just left to its own devices if this
were to happen if a lot of bees were
wanted to be converted into currency a
and because everyone is converting
everyone is afraid to convert it to B
now because they think for whatever
reason that B the country bees in bad
shape then you have this imbalance and
if you left to its own devices the
country B's currency would become
devalued you would need more more bees
to trade for an a4 and a which is just
another way to say B's currency B's
value these value would go down and that
could be a bad thing especially if it's
a pretty steep decline maybe it's a
country that needs to import fuel from
the rest of the world maybe they need to
import food from the rest of the world
and if their currency were to devalue
dramatically then imports could become
very very very expensive and so people
in that country might have to pay double
for gas and double for basic necessities
like food and whatever else and so we
played out a scenario where the central
bank of country B actively tries to
intervene to keep this from happening to
keep the exchange rate stable and so
what they do is they could use they
could use reserves and I'll deuce in
blue for country B so they could use
reserves of a that they've accumulated
during better times and they take those
reserves so these are reserves that they
accumulated in better times or in
previous videos depending on how you
want to view them and they try to
balance out the supply with A's with the
supply of B's by selling by selling
their reserves and buying B's or so one
way they're adding supply of A's and
they're also adding subplot they're also
adding demand for B's they're going to
sell the reserves of a and buy their own
currency and that would work as long as
they have reserves they're going to be
able to stabilize things so that this
situation doesn't happen but the problem
was and we talked about at the end of
the last video is that they can run out
here it's not like they can it's not
like they can print another countries
currencies forever
or they can't print it at all they oh
they had to accumulate this this isn't
their own currency so they have a finite
amount of this they could eventually run
out and what is off in the case is
currency speculators see this and they
begin to smell blood
they see okay look people are trying to
exit this currency it would devalue if
it was left to its own devices but the
central bank of country B is trying to
keep it is trying to keep it from
devaluing by depleting its finite
reserves of currency a and so what
currency speculators will start to do is
well I can go into country B and I can
borrow B's so I literally could go to a
bank and country B and borrow I could
borrow some of the B currency and then I
could go into the exchange markets and
try to convert it into a x' and try to
convert it into a z' and just off of
when looking at the superficially what's
that going to do well this is going to
make the situation even worse for the
central bank because now you have people
actively that it even hold bees before
they're going to be borrowing bees and
then converting them into A's so it's
going to create an even larger supply of
bees and even more demand for the finite
number of A's that are willing to go
this way and why as the speculator doing
this well think about the two situations
for them if for whatever reason let me
write to draw the two scenarios so
scenario one is is that for whatever
reason the central bank of B is able to
keep the currency stabilized so currency
currency stays stays stable and the
other scenario is is that the central
bank runs out of reserves and they have
to essentially just let the currencies
float and B gets devalued so central
bank central bank out of reserves out of
reserves which would mean that the
currencies would float the currencies
would float and B would would devalue
devalue well if this first scenario
happens and it's become it's going to
become more and it's going to become
less and less likely as more and more
people pile on the strategy and more and
more people try to
run out of bees or try to exit bees
currency but even if this situation were
to happen then the speculator says okay
the currency ended up being stable I'll
just unwind this I'll take my A's when I
have to pay off my debt and B I'll take
my A's convert them into B's and pay off
my dad and so depending on what the
interest rates and all of that were not
a big loss or maybe even a minimal loss
so minimal loss minimal loss and only if
there's kind of a differential with
interest rates or things like that
minimal to no loss minimal to no loss
but what happens if the central bank
runs out of reserves and remember just
the fact that these speculators are
doing the speculative attack they're
borrowing and country and converting
into it the car they're borrowing in
country B and converting to a that's
making the central bank run out of
reserves even faster it's going to
deplete their reserves essentially when
they do this it's the central bank of
country B that's going to be giving them
is going to be allowing them to convert
they don't know who they're who they're
buying these B's from with this a
currency they have and so if this
happens that the central bank runs out
of reserves it floats and then B D
values then those currency speculators
make a pretty good buck and just to see
how that could work imagine that they
borrow a hundred B's they borrow a
hundred B's so this is what they borrow
they borrow a hundred B's and while the
the currency is is is being actively
intervened with by the central bank
they're trying to keep it from devaluing
the the exchange rate is one a for one B
so they convert it they're able to
convert - so they convert on the open
market and the only reason why this is
able to happen at this exchange rate is
because B central bank is actively
selling aids they're able to convert to
100 days 100 days now let's say that
they are able to do this and the the
central bank runs out of a's and then a
devaluation occurs so this is happening
this is happening at a conversion of 1 a
equals 1 B but let's say that these guys
they run out of reserves so things
devalue B becomes worth a lot less and
then we go to a future state where 1a is
now equal to 2 B's well as soon as this
happens remember this
this scenario right over here that we're
thinking about right over here this is
what the currency speculators want to
happen if one day all of a sudden is
it's two B's because the central bank
can't intervene anymore they are
floating the cart B gets devalued then
what's going to happen these guys can
take their hundred days convert it back
once the once things are floating so now
they're going to convert back into this
direction and how many B's can they
convert it into well now they can
convert it into 200 B's they can convert
it into 200 B's they can pay off their
debt because they borrowed the 100 B's
so minus 100 B's to pay debt to pay debt
and then they make a pretty sighs
sizable profit they make a profit of 100
B's and so that's exactly what they're
hoping for and so you can imagine this
is one of those trades that they're
going to try to get more and more people
to do because the more people that jump
on the bandwagon and do this exact same
strategy the faster the central bank's
reserves are going to plead and the more
likely the more likely that this
situation this situation right over here
plays out